let's do our cosmic queries and of
course we always start off with a
patreon patron question and if you
support us on patreon we will give your
questions priority here at cosmic
queries okay okay where we basically buy
your loyalty okay here we go
Matthew messing on from Calgary Alberta
hmm
says in your opinion dr. Tyson what was
the most significant thing that the
Apollo program achieved with the
exception of landing on the moon wow
that's that's a good question when you
think about it because everybody you say
Apollo program it's moon landing bang
that's the end of it that's it but he's
saying give me something that is just as
significant that we don't think about
dang so beginning in 1970 a little
earlier but in 1970 was the first Earth
Day nationally and then it became a
rapid international hit if you will
because Earth Day is global man is
global now and it's a significant global
celebration of our home planet and
around that same time so night to
whatever what else happened nineteen
seventy one two and three we would see
the passing of the comprehensive Clean
Air Act Clean Water Act in 1970 NOAA was
founded the National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration to monitor
our climate and our oceans and our
weather and not only that the
Environmental Protection Agency was
founded in 1970 by the time 1973 came
around leaded gas would be banned deed
leaded gas would be banned DDT would be
banned the catalytic converter would be
introduced all of this happened during
the years we were going to the moon at a
time when we had a whole lot of other
stuff distracting us like a cold war
with the Soviet Union and a hot war in
Southeast Asia and campus unrest from
anti-war
protests and the civil rights movement
and assassinations 1968 would see two
assassinations on domestic soil and so
so why am I saying all this because
while we had all these other potential
distractions we nonetheless paused to
reflect on our relationship to our home
planet
so I submit to you that though we went
to the moon to explore the moon upon
getting there and looking back in fact
we would discover earth for the first
time Wow so it's like I've been to
paradise but I've never been to me it's
exactly that so can you put a dollar
figure right on the fact that seeing
earth in the sky from the moon was like
a firmware update in our sense of
awareness and who we are of the
importance of Earth and our relationship
to it right okay that's that's actually
that's a bit more existential than I was
expecting for an answer okay I have to
say it's a damn good answer because it's
more of the the it's more of a
collective conscious enlightenment yes
and I don't think anyone started the
program with that expectation right but
that is clearly a consequence of it and
so and remember that TV commercial with
the Native Americans standing on this on
the and was a tear in his eye I was here
the single tear went and people throwing
garbage out through it that didn't
happen until this period till we were
going to the moon we were total garbage
out the window people for long before
that right never got that about us that
means seriously
garbage out the window pretty much all
through human history all through human
history and the fact that was great for
anthropologists they can find stuff
along the Roman via right you know that
people Oh a McDonald's Cup
poor McDonald's would've been around no
but you you it was we didn't start
thinking of it as a as a cause a
cultural environmental problem until
that that period Wow okay wow that's a
hey Matthew I you know I hope you're
satisfied with that answer because it
was a completely curved complete
curveball with that answer
and then there's tang that and tang a
close second there you go